the team hosting a birthday party at
City National Arena ahead of the team's
practice festivities begin early this
morning at 8 30. get the kids take them
in fans who attend may be able to stay
for the team's final practice as well
that starts at 11 30. there's going to
be a DJ and inflatable rink foods and
drink food and drinks a poster making
station as well but here's the thing
only the first 250 fans there will be
able to stay for the practice on the ice
so you want to get there early it is
going to be jam-packed yeah there's
usually a line outside that gathers for
people to want to get in size yes then
get ready bring cake for chance